>> (screaming)
>> THE 13 FINALISTS
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
HAVE BEEN THROUGH
A GRUELING COMPETITION.
SOME REACHED GREAT HEIGHTS,
AND OTHERS WERE ALL WASHED UP.
>> AAH! (laughs)
>> THREE GIRLS
HAVE SURVIVED IT ALL,
AND TONIGHT,
ONE OF THEM WILL BE NAMED
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL IT BE NATASHA...
>> (in Russian) HI.
>> THE RUSSIAN BEAUTY AND MOM
WHO STARTED THE COMPETITION
KNOWING THE LEAST
ABOUT MODELING...
>> LIKE, SHOULD I BE INNOCENT
OR MORE SEXY?
>> AND WAS ALMOST ELIMINATED?
NATASHA.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> NATASHA'S
OPTIMISTIC ATTITUDE...
>> I LOVE THIS PICTURE ANYWAYS
BECAUSE IT'S SO MUCH BETTER
COMPARED TO OTHER PICTURES
I HAD.
>> YOU'RE THE BEST SALESMAN
IN THE WORLD.
AND ABILITY TO LEARN
TURNED THINGS AROUND.
>> BUT THERE IS A REASON
THOSE RUSSIAN PEOPLE COMPETE
AND GET GOLD.
>> NATASHA
HAS IMPROVED THE MOST,
BUT IS IT ENOUGH TO WIN?
>> (singsongy) I'M BACK!
>> (laughs)
OR WILL IT BE JASLENE,
THE LATIN SPITFIRE
WHO DIDN'T MAKE THE CUT
CYCLE 7?
OH!
>> I'M NOT GIVING UP.
>> YOU SHOULDN'T GIVE UP.
JASLENE PROVED TO BE
A FORCE TO RECKON WITH
THIS TIME AROUND.
SHE CONSISTENTLY TOOK
AMAZING PHOTOS.
>> OH, MY GOD! THAT'S GORGEOUS!
>> BUT THE ENERGETIC
PERSONALITY THAT GOT HER
INTO THE COMPETITION
WAS FADING AWAY
IN FRONT OF THE JUDGES.
>> I DON'T SEE YOU, THE MODEL,
RIGHT HERE.
>> CAN JASLENE FIND A WAY
TO EMBRACE HER PERSONALITY
WITHOUT BEING OVER-THE-TOP?
OR WILL IT BE RENEE,
THE STUNNING MOTHER FROM HAWAII
WHO KEPT HER EYE ON THE PRIZE?
>> I HAVE A FAMILY TO TAKE CARE
OF.
I WANNA MAKE THINGS GOOD FOR
THEM.
>> SHE TOOK AMAZING PHOTOS
BUT AGGRAVATED HER COMPETITORS.
>> YOU WANNA GET UP IN MY FACE?!
>> YOU'VE BEEN DISRESPECTFUL
TO EVERY SINGLE GIRL IN THIS
HOUSE.
>> AFTER BEING CONFRONTED...
>> I'M SORRY
FOR ANYTHING I MIGHT HAVE SAID.
>> RENEE EVENTUALLY
FOUND A BALANCE
BETWEEN HER COMPETITIVE
AND NURTURING SIDES.
>> RENEE IS DEFINITELY
A PRETTY GIRL.
SHE JUST DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
THE YOUNGEST, FRESHEST FACE
ON THE BLOCK.
>> WILL RENEE FIND A WAY
TO RETAIN HER MATERNAL GLOW
WHILE STAYING SEXY AND YOUNG?
FIND OUT TONIGHT WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP?
♪ ♪
>> WELL, WELL, WELL,
THE THREE LOVELY LADIES.
SO WE KNOW WHAT DATE
IT IS TODAY, RIGHT?
IT'S THE COVERGIRL DAY!
>> YAY!
>> RIGHT!
WHOEVER BECOMES
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
THE "PRINT AD"
THAT WE SHOOT TODAY
IS GONNA BE IN A REAL MAGAZINE,
AND IT'S GONNA BE SEEN
BY MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
>> EVER SINCE I WAS LITTLE,
I HAVE DREAMED
OF BEING A COVERGIRL.
ME AND MY SISTERS,
WE USED TO PRACTICE
THE COVERGIRL WINK.
"OH, YOU DIDN'T DO IT RIGHT.
IT'S LIKE THIS..." (bell dings)
>> THE PRODUCT YOU'RE SELLING
TODAY IS THE NEW
COVERGIRL TruShine LIPCOLOR,
AND WE'RE ALSO GONNA
SHOOT A SEGMENT
YOU MIGHT BE FAMILIAR WITH.
IT'S CALLED
"MY LIFE AS A COVERGIRL."
NOW, RENEE, YOU'RE GOING TO BE
ON A BOAT IN THE HARBOUR.
JASLENE, YOU'RE GONNA BE
STEPPING OUT OF A CAR
ONTO A RED CARPET.
I KNOW YOU CAN GIVE ME
A LITTLE FABULOUS, CAN'T YOU?
>> OH, YES! FABULOUS!
>> AND, NATASHA,
YOU ARE GOING TO BE
BACKSTAGE AT A PHOTO STUDIO
TALKING ABOUT
THE TruShine LIPCOLOR.
THERE'S NO SCRIPT TODAY.
YOU'LL BE AD-LIBBING.
SO BRING ME YOUR PERSONALITY,
WHO YOU REALLY, REALLY ARE.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> YES.
>> NOW I HAD TO GET
A GREAT PHOTOGRAPHER
TO SHOOT THE PRINT AD.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> HE'S NOT ONLY SHOT
SOME OF TYRA'S FAVORITE PHOTOS
OF HERSELF--
HE'S ALSO SHOT
CARIDEE AND DANIELLE'S
COVERGIRL ADS.
HIS NAME IS JIM DeYONKER.
>> HI!
>> SO BASICALLY,
YOU'RE GONNA BE ON YOUR OWN
WITH JIM TODAY,
BUT I'LL BE THERE
WHEN WE'RE SHOOTING
YOUR "MY LIFE" SEGMENTS.
BUT I STILL THINK YOU MIGHT NEED
A LITTLE EXTRA COACHING.
WHERE'S MY LITTLE COVERGIRL?
>> HI!
>> AAH!
OH, MY GOD!
>> HI, LADIES!
>> CARIDEE!
LOOK IT, ISN'T SHE GORGEOUS?
AS YOU KNOW,
CARIDEE WAS THE WINNER
OF CYCLE 7,
SO SHE'S BEEN THROUGH
ALL OF THIS BEFORE.
>> IT'S SO GOOD TO SEE YOU GUYS.
I KNOW YOU'RE
SUPER, SUPER NERVOUS,
AND YOU'RE PROBABLY
REALLY, REALLY TIRED.
I MEAN, MY LIFE AS A COVERGIRL
HAS BEEN GREAT.
DON'T OVERTHINK TODAY,
AND JUST BEING YOUR TRUE SELF
REALLY HELPS.
AND, UM, I'M SO GLAD
I'M NOT YOU RIGHT NOW.
>> (laughs)
>> OOH!
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> THIS IS EASY
COMPARED TO WHAT IT IS
AFTER YOU WIN.
>> YEAH?
>> IT'S GOOD.
YOU JUST GOTTA BE STRONG.
>> I'M EXCITED FOR THAT.
>> I GAVE A BUNCH OF THE GIRLS
ADVICE, KIND OF JUST HELP 'EM,
AND IT'S GOOD TO HEAR,
LIKE, THE ADVICE
OF SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN THERE
AS OPPOSED TO SOMEONE
WHO JUST WANTS YOU TO DO WELL.
>> SO, NATASHA,
THERE'S A LITTLE ADDED PRESSURE
TODAY
BECAUSE BRENT OVERSEES ALL THE
"MY LIFE" SPOTS.
SO IT'S NOT ABOUT
JUST PLEASING ME AND THE JUDGES.
IT'S REALLY
PLEASING THE CLIENTS.
>> IF YOU WIN,
THIS IS GONNA BE THE FIRST
"MY LIFE AS A COVERGIRL"
THAT RUNS FOR YOU.
>> IT'S VERY NERVE-RACKING.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
HOW YOU DO COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL,
AND I HAVE TO BRING IT ON.
>> YOU'RE NOT SCRIPTED TODAY,
BUT THERE ARE A FEW LINES.
RIGHT, BRENT?
>> CORRECT.
>> THAT YOU HAVE TO LAND.
>> "NEW TruShine LIPCOLOR
HAS SHEER, SHINY SHADES
THAT MATCH 97% OF SKIN TONES."
>> I'M JUST
TALKING ABOUT MY LIFE BECAUSE
I JUST WON A COMPETITION,
AND NOW I'M A COVERGIRL.
>> ROLLING.
>> TAKE ONE.
>> HI. I'M NATASHA, AND THIS IS
MY LIFE AS A COVERGIRL.
BEING A MODEL,
I GO FROM ONE PHOTO SHOOT
TO ANOTHER.
>> NATASHA WROTE OUT A SCRIPT.
SHE MEMORIZED IT,
AND IT SOUNDED LIKE SHE WAS
RECITING HER GROCERY LIST.
>> CUT IT.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE A SCRIPT.
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND
A SPONTANEITY...
>> MM-HMM.
>> THAT I KNOW YOU POSSESS.
>> THIS WON'T WORK.
>> OKAY.
BEING A COVERGIRL WAS ALWAYS MY
DREAM.
I ALWAYS WANTED TO BE A MODEL.
AND NOW
AFTER WINNING THE COMPETITION...
>> (whispers) MUCH BETTER.
>> (whispers indistinctly)
>> SO I BOOKED A LOT OF JOBS,
AND I'M A SUCCESSFUL MODEL.
WAS IT BETTER?
>> (laughing)
>> YES, SO MUCH BETTER!
>> THAT IS SO MUCH BETTER,
NATASHA.
>> DON'T DO THAT,
'CAUSE THAT'S WHEN IT'S, LIKE,
PUCKER.
BE CHIC LIKE A T-SHIRT DRESS.
IT JUST HAPPENS
TO BE MADE OF SEQUINS.
>> MY ASSIGNMENT
IS THE SYDNEY HARBOUR BRIDGE
AND THE OPERA HOUSE.
IT FEELS WEIRD
TO DO A COMMERCIAL WITHOUT ANY
LINES,
'CAUSE MOST COMMERCIALS, YOU
KNOW,
YOU HAVE LINES TO MEMORIZE.
I DON'T KNOW, I FEEL STRANGE.
>> AND ACTION.
>> ALOHA. IT'S RENEE
IN BEAUTIFUL SYDNEY, AUSTRALIA.
I HAD A BABY NINE MONTHS AGO,
AND I THOUGHT THAT MY LIFE WAS
OVER.
>> WE WERE LIKE, WOMP, WOMP,
WOMP.
CUT IT.
>> CUT.
>> YOU PROBABLY DON'T WANNA SAY,
"I HAD A BABY NINE MONTHS AGO,
AND I THOUGHT MY LIFE WAS OVER."
IT'S, LIKE, YOU WANNA
TALK ABOUT THINGS IN A POSITIVE
WAY.
>> OKAY.
>> BUT AS SOON AS WE GAVE RENEE
THAT NOTE,
SHE FLIPPED IT AROUND 180.
>> I'M THE NEW FACE
FOR THE NEW TruShine LIPCOLOR
FROM COVERGIRL.
ITS SHEER, SHINY SHADES
MATCH 97% OF ALL SKIN TONES.
LITTLE, OLD RENEE, YOU KNOW,
WIFE AND MOTHER--
I JUST FEEL EASY, BREEZY
AND BEAUTIFUL.
>> COULD YOU ASK FOR ANYTHING
MORE?
>> I MEAN, I'M SO EXCITED.
>> CUT IT!
OKAY, THAT WAS, LIKE,
SO DISGUSTINGLY GOOD.
AND THEN YOU WENT
"EASY, BREEZY AND BEAUTIFUL"?!
I THINK BRENT FELL TO THE FLOOR.
>> (laughs)
>> SO... (laughs)
>> SMILE. THERE YOU GO.
LOOKS BEAUTIFUL.
>> I LOVE MY SCENARIO.
I LIVE FOR THE FABULOUS LIFE.
IT'S ME.
IT COULDN'T BE ANY BETTER.
SHEER, SHINY SHADES
MATCHES 97% OF SKIN TONES.
>> JASLENE, CAN YOU HEAR ME?
>> Yes.
>> I NEED CHA-CHA TO COME
FORWARD.
I NEED YOU TO BE
TALKING TO YOUR GIRLFRIEND,
SAYING, "HEY, THIS IS MY LIFE."
JASLENE HAS THIS ENERGY,
THIS FIRE, AND, YOU KNOW,
WHEN WE STARTED OFF,
IT WAS REALLY KIND OF TAME.
>> HEY, THIS IS MY LIFE.
>> THAT'S REALLY UNFORTUNATE,
BECAUSE TODAY IS THE DAY
WE WANTED TO SEE
JASLENE'S TRUE SELF.
>> BEING A COVERGIRL
IS ALL ABOUT THE FABULOUS LIFE.
Y YO, COMO LATINA, ME GUSTA.
>> OH, I LOVE THAT SHE DID THAT
IN SPANISH!
>> PERFECT.
>> THIS IS MY LIFE AS A
COVERGIRL.
>> I THINK WE GOT ENOUGH.
THAT'S A WRAP.
>> YEAH. GOOD. NOW LET'S...
NOW YOU WANNA DO LIKE THIS
AGAIN. TRY THAT.
>> CARIDEE'S TEACHING ME
HOW TO PROLONG MY NECK,
MAKE IT, UH, LOOK VERY LONG
AND VERY BEAUTIFUL
FOR THE PHOTO SHOOT
FOR THE COVERGIRL,
BECAUSE SHE'S ALREADY DONE IT.
>> SUBTLE MOVEMENTS.
IT'S WITH THE EYES,
IT'S WITH THE MOUTH.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> GOOD. NICE.
CHIN UP AND OUT.
YEAH, THERE YOU GO. THAT'S NICE.
>> (laughs)
>> SHE'S GONNA START
MAKING US ALL LAUGH! (laughs)
>> (laughing)
>> BETTER GET ONE OF THOSE.
NATASHA DEFINITELY
LIKES TO LAUGH.
NOT THAT BIG. THERE YOU GO.
BUT NATASHA DEFINITELY STRUGGLES
WITH SMILES.
SHE HAS TO ALMOST LAUGH
IN ORDER TO GET A SMILE.
SHE CAN'T FAKE IT.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH!
>> VERY GOOD JOB.
>> THANK YOU. (laughs)
>> MAN, YOU GOT ENERGY, GIRL.
>> (laughs)
>> I'LL TAKE A LOT OF SHOTS.
WE'RE GONNA DO THE SHOTS
RIGHT HERE, ALL RIGHT?
>> OKAY. GREAT.
>> THAT'S GOOD. NICE ENERGY.
I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA BE--
SMILING ALL THE TIME,
IT GETS REALLY TIRING.
>> YEAH, I KNOW.
I'M SURPRISED AT HOW HARD IT IS
TO SMILE.
YOUR MUSCLES TENSE UP
RIGHT HERE, AND, YOU KNOW,
SMILING,
MY LIPS STARTED SHAKING.
I HAD TO STOP AND JUST RELAX,
PUFF UP MY CHEEKS.
>> WHO'S NEXT? RENEE?
>> WHO IS NEXT?
>> THE COVERGIRL.
>> OOH!
>> OH, SHE'S GOT,
"I'M GONNA WIN THIS"
IN HER HEAD.
>> (laughs)
>> RENEE WAS GREAT,
BUT RENEE DEFINITELY LOOKS OLDER
THAN THE OTHER GIRLS.
SHE SEEMS ALMOST TOO MATURE
TO BE STARTING OFF
IN THE MODELING INDUSTRY.
GREAT. OKAY, WE GOT THIS.
>> YAY!
♪ ♪
>> IT'S TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW,
YOU WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY TWO OF YOU WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> ALL THE GIRLS DID VERY WELL
ON THEIR SHOOTS,
SO I THINK IT'S JUST GONNA BE
UP TO THE JUDGES.
BUT I WOULD HOPE
THAT THEY DON'T LET NATASHA
DO THE FINAL RUNWAY
BECAUSE SHE WALKS LIKE
A PIGEON-TOED DUCK
WITH A PIECE OF POOP
HANGING OUT OF HER ASS.
(laughs)
>> I'M NERVOUS
BECAUSE THERE IS ALWAYS A CHANCE
THAT YOU CAN BE SENT HOME.
BUT I FEEL LIKE
JASLENE IS THE NEXT TO GO
BECAUSE SHE, UH,
NEED TO GIVE MORE PERSONALITY
IN HER PICTURES.
>> WHEN YOU WALK IN PANEL,
YOU THINK YOU'VE DONE
SUCH A GOOD JOB,
AND THEY'RE GONNA LIKE ME
AND THIS AND THAT.
BUT, LIKE, YOU NEVER KNOW.
EXPECT THE UNEXPECTED.
♪ ♪
>> WELL, HELLO, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> HOW DOES IT FEEL
TO BE THE FINAL THREE?
>> REALLY GOOD.
>> THREE BADDEST BITCHES
IN TOWN!
>> (laughs)
>> HOLLA!
MR. NIGEL BARKER IS HERE,
OUR FIRST JUDGE,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER...
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
RUNWAY DIVA COACH
EXTRAORDINAIRE...
AND TWIGGY,
LEGENDARY ICON...
AND WE HAVE SARAH-JANE CLARKE
AND HEIDI MIDDLETON,
THE DYNAMIC DESIGN DUO
OF SASS & BIDE.
>> OH, MY GOD!
(laughter)
>> HI.
>> THEY ARE
THE TOP FASHION DESIGNERS
IN AUSTRALIA,
AND THEY ARE THE FIRST
AUSTRALIAN DUO TO EVER SHOW
IN NEW YORK'S FASHION WEEK.
AND THE FINAL TWO GIRLS
WILL BE WALKING
IN A SASS & BIDE FASHION SHOW.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DETERMINE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
FIRST UP, WE HAVE NATASHA.
SO THIS WEEK, YOU SHOT
A "MY LIFE AS A COVERGIRL"
COMMERCIAL,
AND WE'RE GONNA WATCH
YOUR BEST TAKE.
>> IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR ME
TO STAY PRETTY AND FEEL PRETTY,
AND THAT'S WHERE
TruShine LIPCOLOR
COMES OUT AND HELPS ME.
ITS SHEER, SHINY SHADES
MATCHES 97% OF THE SKIN TONES,
AND I LOVE IT BECAUSE
IT MATCHES MY SKIN TONE, TOO.
UM...
THAT'S IT.
NO?
(laughter)
>> (laughs)
>> (imitates Natasha) THAT'S IT.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE LINES TO REMEMBER,
YOU ARE ABLE TO FOCUS
ON THOSE WORDS AND DELIVER
AND HAVE PERSONALITY.
HERE, YOU HAD TO AD-LIB,
SO THERE WAS A LOT OF STUMBLING.
>> AD-LIBBING, I THINK,
IS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE HARDEST THINGS TO DO.
AND I CAN'T IMAGINE
WHAT IT MUST BE LIKE,
HAVING ENGLISH
AS YOUR SECOND LANGUAGE.
>> NATASHA,
WHAT MAKES YOU SO SPECIAL
IS THAT WHEN YOU LAUGHED
YOU GRABBED YOUR HAIR.
THOSE THINGS ARE ENDEARING
AND LOVELY.
YOUR IMPERFECTIONS ARE OFTEN
WHAT MAKE YOU SO BEAUTIFUL.
>> ALL RIGHT,
YOU ALSO HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> IT'S NOT MY FAVORITE
PHOTOGRAPH OF YOU,
BUT I DO THINK
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
I MEAN, THE CAMERA LOVES YOU.
FOR SELLING LIP PRODUCT,
YOU'RE THE PERFECT CANDIDATE.
>> THE THING FOR ME IN THIS SHOT
IS THAT THE EYES LOOK
A LITTLE LIKE
THEY'RE QUESTIONING.
>> LOVELY BIG, FULL LIPS,
THOUGH.
>> OH, YEAH. SHE HAS ALL THE
PIECES,
ALL THE BITS AND PIECES
YOU NEED--THE MOUTH, THE NOSE,
EVERYTHING'S GREAT.
CONFIDENCE IN THE EYES,
THAT'S WHAT SELLS A PICTURE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT, NATASHA, THANK
YOU.
UP NEXT IS JASLENE.
AND JASLENE WAS
A SUPERMODEL ON THE RED CARPET.
>> SHEER, SHINY SHADES
THAT MATCHES 97% OF SKIN TONES.
Y YO, COMO LATINA,
IT WOULD GO PERFECT
WITH MY SKIN.
>> (laughs)
>> I THINK THAT WAS DIFFERENT.
>> I'LL FIRST--I'LL START OFF
WITH ADDING THE SPANISH,
THAT WAS GENIUS.
>> YES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BUT HOW YOU DELIVERED IT...
>> AH!
>> AND PAUSED...
>> UGH!
>> BETWEEN EVERYTHING?
>> YES.
>> NAH. ALL RIGHT, JASLENE,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> IT'S VERY PRETTY INDEED.
AND I-I'M PLEASED TO SAY
THAT YOUR JAWLINE
DOESN'T LOOK REALLY BIG
IN THIS SHOT.
>> MM-HMM.
>> 'CAUSE YOU TEND TO DO THIS...
LEAD WITH YOUR JAW, PHOTOGRAPH
WITH YOUR JAW.
>> I THINK YOUR EYES
ARE REALLY QUITE ENGAGING THERE,
AND I THINK IT'S A REALLY GREAT
SHOT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> JASLENE, I THOUGHT
YOU WERE A LITTLE NERVOUS BEING
SO COMMERCIAL.
LIKE, IN--IN THE PHOTOS,
IT'S NOT YOUR THING,
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO FIND--
HOW TO BE SWEET AND BEAUTIFUL,
'CAUSE YOU'RE A SWEET, BEAUTIFUL
GIRL,
BUT I KNOW YOU'RE MORE
COMFORTABLE
WHEN YOU'RE...
>> (laughs)
>> GRACIAS.
>> ALL RIGHT, RENEE, YOUR TURN.
>> I'M SO HAPPY.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
LOOK... LOOK WHERE I AM!
I AM IN SYDNEY, AUSTRALIA.
I'M SITTING ON
THIS BEAUTIFUL BOAT,
AND I'M JUST HAVING
THE TIME OF MY LIFE.
>> WELL, ONE THING I CAN SAY,
I FELT LIKE
YOU REALLY BELIEVED IT.
>> YOU CAUGHT THE EXCITEMENT
VERY, VERY WELL.
>> YEAH.
>> AND I THOUGHT YOU SPOKE VERY
WELL OF IT.
>> ONE THING THAT I LIKED IS
YOUR EXCITEMENT WAS, UM, HUMBLE.
IT WAS LIKE, "OH , MY GOD! LOOK
AT MY LIFE!"
SO IF I'M, LIKE, A YOUNG GIRL
LOOKING AT THE TELEVISION,
I'M LIKE, "WOW, THAT COULD BE
ME, TOO."
>> MM-HMM.
>> WAS IT EXTREMELY BRIGHT
WHERE YOU WERE?
>> OH, IT WAS SO BRIGHT.
AND THEY HAD THOSE, UH,
REFLECTOR THINGS.
>> THAT WAS THE BIGGEST PROBLEM,
WAS THE FACT THAT YOUR EYES,
WHICH ARE SO GORGEOUS...
>> YES, THE LIGHT. YEAH.
>> I HARDLY COULD SEE THEM.
THEY WERE GONE.
>> YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR COVERGIRL, AND, UH,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
HEALTHY, OUTDOOR...
>> OUT OF ALL THE GIRLS,
YOU WERE SO COMFORTABLE
DOING THIS.
YOU LOOKED LIKE
YOU WERE HAVING FUN.
>> THE THING FOR ME, THOUGH,
IS THAT YOU DO PHOTOGRAPH
QUITE OLD-LOOKING.
AND IT'S A-- SUCH A
SOPHISTICATED LOOK.
IT'S SUCH A SORT OF MATURE LOOK.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH
IT, ACTUALLY.
IT'S FUNNY.
>> THE ONE THING I HAVE TO SAY
IS YOU DID LOOK OLDER
THAN THE OTHER GIRLS.
LIKE, YOU HAVE, LIKE,
A KIND OF A PUFFINESS AND, LIKE,
KIND OF A WRINKLING.
MAYBE IT'S FROM THE SUN.
SO SOMETHING
TO BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT,
BECAUSE THE FASHION INDUSTRY
IS SO OBSESSED WITH YOUTH.
>> RIGHT.
>> THE MINUTE THEY START SEEING
ANY TYPE OF AGE, THEY'RE LIKE,
"UGH, ON TO THE NEXT."
AND IT'S AN AWFUL SAD THING
IN THE INDUSTRY, BUT IT'S--
BUT IT'S A TRUTH...
>> (whispers) TRUTH.
>> THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT, WE HAVE
GOT TO DELIBERATE AND DECIDE
WHICH ONE OF YOU IS GOING HOME
AND WHICH TWO FINALISTS
ARE GONNA BE
STOMPING IT TO THE DEATH
IN THE SASS & BIDE FASHION SHOW.
I'LL CALL YOU BACK
IN A LITTLE BIT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANKS.
♪ ♪
>> SO NOW IT'S TIME TO DECIDE
WHO'S GONNA BE THE FINAL TWO.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> NATASHA.
>> I PERSONALLY THINK
SHE IS THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
OF THE THREE.
HER PROPORTIONS ARE
EXTRAORDINARY ON HER FACE.
I-I THINK SHE COULD
BE A TOP MODEL BECAUSE
SHE'S SO EXTRAORDINARY-LOOKING.
>> LADIES?
>> SHE MIGHT BE MISSING
A LITTLE BIT OF THAT "X" FACTOR
OR THAT NATURAL STYLE
THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
FOR A TOP MODEL.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
SHE'S A GREAT LEARNER.
SHE'S A QUICK STUDY,
AND I THINK SHE'S JUST
IMPROVED, IMPROVED, IMPROVED.
AND WHEN WE LET THEM GO,
WE WANT SOMEONE
WHO'S GONNA CONTINUE TO IMPROVE.
>> THERE IS SOMETHING
ABOUT NATASHA,
THAT WHEN SHE COMES IN,
SHE STILL TOUCHES MY HEART.
THERE'S THIS PERSONALITY,
THIS VIVACIOUSNESS
THAT I REALLY LOVE FROM HER.
AND I JUST FEEL LIKE
IF YOU GIVE HER A CHANCE,
SHE'LL DO IT. SHE...
>> YEAH, SHE TAKES IT ON.
>> FAST.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> JASLENE.
>> I THINK JASLENE IS AMAZING,
REALLY SPECTACULARLY PRETTY,
AND I HAVEN'T REALLY
SEEN A GIRL LIKE THIS IN A
WHILE.
>> I ACTUALLY LOVE
HER OTHER PHOTOGRAPHS
WHERE SHE'S EDGY AND TOUGH.
BUT IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH, SHE--
YOU WOULDN'T LOOK AT THAT
AND THINK, OH,
THAT'S AN AMAZING NEW TOP MODEL.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE
JASLENE, CLASS OF...
>> YEAH.
>> 2005, HIGH SCHOOL.
>> THE GLAMOUR PHOTO SHOT
IN THE SHOPPING MALL.
>> MM.
>> BUT SHE KNOWS HOW TO TAKE A
FIERCE PICTURE.
>> OOH!
>> SHE DOES.
>> OOH! SHE'S FIERCE!
>> YES!
RENEE.
>> I LOVED WHAT SHE DID ON HER
COMMERCIAL.
IT WAS FULL OF JOIE DE VIVRE,
AND SHE'S AMUSING.
SHE LOOKS GORGEOUS.
BUT I--THIS IS
THE BEST PHOTOGRAPH
THIS WEEK FOR ME.
>> I THINK RENEE'S PHOTO
IS REALLY, REALLY BEAUTIFUL,
BUT IT JUST LOOKS A LITTLE...
TOO MATURE.
I MEAN, I THINK AT 60,
YOU WANNA LOOK LIKE RENEE AT 40.
>> (laughs)
>> YEAH, I KNOW.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT.
I'VE SEEN THIS FACE BEFORE.
>> MM-HMM.
>> IT'S NOT THE FRESHEST FACE
FOR ME,
AND I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> MM!
RENEE'S GOT THE HEIGHT
AND THE BODY.
>> SHE'S GOT A GREAT BODY.
>> THE OTHER TWO HAVE GOT
THE FACES AND THE OOMPH.
SO NOW IT IS TIME TO DECIDE
WHO OUR FINAL TWO
ARE GOING TO BE.
>> OH, GOD!
I HATE THIS. IT'S SO HARD.
♪ ♪
>> THREE OF YOU STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE TWO PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE TWO PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS
BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AFTER I'VE ANNOUNCED
OUR DECISION,
OUR TWO FINALISTS
WILL GO TO A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR A "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE
COVER.
AND TOMORROW, THEY'LL FACE OFF
IN A SASS & BIDE FASHION SHOW.
THE GIRL'S NAME I DO NOT CALL
WILL PACK HER BAGS AND GO HOME.
THE FIRST NAME I'M GOING TO
CALL...
JASLENE.
>> JASLENE, YOU ARE A FINALIST
IN THIS COMPETITION.
SO HOW DOES IT FEEL
TO COME THIS FAR
AFTER NOT EVEN MAKING IT LAST
CYCLE?
>> (voice breaks) IT FEELS SO
GOOD. SO, SO, GOOD.
>> WELL, YOU WORKED HARD.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> WILL RENEE AND NATASHA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO IN MY
HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
BOTH OF YOU HAVE
VERY DIFFERENT STRENGTHS
AND VERY DIFFERENT WEAKNESSES.
NATASHA, YOU COME INTO THIS ROOM
WITH A SMILE ON YOUR FACE
ALL THE TIME.
SOMEONE THAT STARTED SO SHAKY
BUT HAS GOTTEN BETTER AND
BETTER.
BUT WE LOOK AT YOUR COVERGIRL
PERFORMANCE,
AND WE SEE SOMETHING
THAT IS VERY WEAK.
THAT MAKES THE JUDGES
VERY NERVOUS.
THEN WE LOOK AT YOU, RENEE--
STRONG WOMAN OUT ON A VENGEANCE
TO MAKE HER FAMILY'S LIFE
BETTER.
A GIRL THAT HAS DONE
BEAUTIFUL PHOTOS WEEK TO WEEK.
BUT THEN THE JUDGES SAID
THEY'VE SEEN YOUR FACE BEFORE.
AND A LOT OF THEM--
AND I HATE TO SAY THIS--
BUT THEY KEEP SAYING
THAT YOU LOOK OLDER
THAN YOU ARE.
SO WHO GOES HOME--
THE GIRL WITH
THE BUBBLING PERSONALITY,
OR THE GIRL
THAT TAKES AMAZING PHOTOS?
>> NATASHA.
>> OH!
♪ ♪
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> THE REASON WHY
YOUR NAME WAS CALLED THIS WEEK
IS BECAUSE
WHAT THE JUDGES NOTICE ABOUT YOU
IS THAT YOU TAKE A CRITIQUE,
AND THEN NEXT WEEK,
YOU'RE AMAZING.
SO THEY'RE LOOKING
AT ALL THIS POTENTIAL
THAT YOU HAVE, AND WE THINK
THAT AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
NEEDS TO HAVE
A BRIGHT, SHINING PERSONALITY
LIKE YOURS.
SO THAT'S WHY YOU STAND HERE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, TYRA.
>> (whispers) RENEE.
(normal voice) YOU CAME
SO, SO FAR.
SO FAR.
AND YOU SHOULD STILL
BE PROUD OF YOURSELF,
AND WE THINK YOU'RE FABULOUS.
YOU'RE NOT A FINALIST,
BUT YOU'RE STILL FIERCE.
OKAY?
>> (whispers) OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
♪ ♪
>> I'M COMPLETELY BLOWN AWAY
BY THE JUDGES' DECISION.
I HAD THE BEST COMMERCIAL.
I HAD THE BEST PICTURE.
APPARENTLY,
THAT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH FOR THEM.
APPARENTLY, I LOOK OLD.
(exhales deeply)
(laughs) OKAY. THAT'S FINE.
I WOULD RATHER
HAVE WISDOM IN MY EYES
AND KNOWLEDGE IN MY HEAD
THAN JUST BE BLANK AND STUPID
AND NOT HAVE ANYTHING THERE.
♪ ♪
>> CONGRATULATIONS
ON MAKING IT TO THE FINAL TWO.
>> THANK YOU!
>> YOU MUST BE SO EXCITED.
>> YEAH!
>> VERY EXCITED.
>> YOU'RE HERE TO SHOOT
YOUR "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE COVER,
BUT ONLY ONE OF YOU
WILL ACTUALLY BE ON THE COVER
OF "SEVENTEEN."
THIS IS A DEFINING MOMENT
FOR ANY MODEL.
ONE OF THE ITEMS
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
IS THIS HOODED SWEATSHIRT
FROM SOUTHPOLE.
THIS KIND OF COLOR
TOTALLY POPS ON THE COVER.
♪ ♪
>> I'M DEFINITELY SURPRISED
THAT NATASHA'S HERE
AND RENEE'S NOT.
IF NATASHA WINS
THIS COMPETITION,
I'M-A PULL OFF ALL HER HAIR.
>> I FEEL LIKE
I'M DOING THIS FOR MYSELF,
BUT I ALSO DO IT FOR MY BABY.
IF I WIN, I'M GONNA BE HAPPY.
AND, OF COURSE,
MY BABIES DON'T WANT
UNHAPPY WOMAN
TO BE RAISING THEM.
>> YES.
SMILE WITH YOUR EYES.
NICE.
>> (voice breaking) IF MY FAMILY
WERE TO BE STANDING HERE,
I KNOW THEY WOULD BE
SO PROUD OF ME ALREADY,
YOU KNOW, MAKING IT THIS FAR,
BUT I KNOW THERE'S STILL MORE
TO GO.
THIS IS NOT THE FINISH LINE.
>> THAT'S A WRAP.
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY.
>> YES!
(applause)
>> THANKS!
>> BYE.
♪ ♪
>> OH, MY GOSH! TYRA!
OH, MY GOD! TYRA!
(squeals and laughs)
>> COME IN!
SIT DOWN!
HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M GREAT.
>> YOU'RE SO HAPPY!
>> (laughs) YEAH!
>> WHY DON'T YOU TELL ME
ABOUT YOUR LIFE IN RUSSIA?
'CAUSE I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT.
>> MY MOM COULDN'T AFFORD, UH,
TO PUT ME IN THE UNIVERSITY
BECAUSE IT WAS SO EXPENSIVE...
>> MM-HMM.
>> IN MY CITY,
SO I MOVED TO MOSCOW,
AND IT'S A HUGE CITY,
AND I DIDN'T KNOW ANYBODY.
AND THERE WAS TIMES THAT I,
LIKE,
DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING--
LIKE, NOTHING.
>> NOTHING TO EAT?
>> NOTHING.
>> AND WHAT'S THE HARDEST THING
IN THIS COMPETITION THAT YOU'VE
HAD TO DEAL WITH?
>> I-I WAS ALWAYS CONCERNED
WHAT GIRLS THINK ABOUT ME,
BECAUSE I-I REALLY WANTED
TO BE FRIENDS WITH THE GIRLS.
>> DO YOU THINK
THEY WERE EVER UPSET THAT YOU
HAD IMMIGRATED FROM RUSSIA
AND THAT THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE
AND COMPETITION IS CALLED
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"?
>> MNH-MNH,
I DON'T--I DON'T THINK,
BECAUSE AMERICA
IS THE MELTING POT
OF NATIONALITIES.
I AM AN AMERICAN,
AND I FEEL MYSELF
AS AN AMERICAN.
>> YOU HAVE A FASHION SHOW
COMING UP.
RELAX THE NECK,
RELAX YOUR FACE,
AND I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
DO REALLY WELL.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, TYRA!
>> YOU'RE--YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> CAN I GET A HUG?
>> YES.
>> (laughs) GIVE ME A HUG.
HI, JASLENE!
>> HI!
(kisses)
>> HAVE A SEAT.
>> OH!
>> DO YOU REMEMBER THAT DAY--
I'M GONNA TAKE YOU WAY BACK--
LAST SEASON,
AND I WAS STANDING UP
IN FRONT OF ALL THE GIRLS
AND DID NOT CALL YOUR NAME.
>> I WAS JUST THINKING,
WHAT DID I DO WRONG?
I FELT LIKE
I HAD THE BIGGEST HEART.
>> SO WHAT DID YOU DO TO PREPARE
TO COME BACK FOR CYCLE 8?
>> WELL, I STARTED
THINKING ABOUT
BUILDING MY CHARACTER.
I WAS JUST ABOUT
SATISFYING EVERYBODY ELSE
BESIDES MYSELF,
AND I REALIZED THAT I'M GONNA
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THERAPY,
BUILD MYSELF UP, LOVE MYSELF
AND COME BACK.
THIS IS MY SECOND CHANCE.
LITERALLY, THIS HAS BEEN
A LIFE-CHANGING EXPERIENCE
FOR ME.
LIKE--I DON'T WANT TO CRY,
I'VE CRIED TOO MUCH,
BUT IT REALLY HAS BEEN.
>> THAT'S OKAY.
>> (crying) AND I'M JUST
THINKING, LIKE,
JASLENE, THIS IS IT. YOU KNOW,
LIKE,
I'M LETTING GO OF MY PAST.
BUT NOW I STAND SO STRONG, TYRA,
AND I WANNA THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT.
OH.
>> WELL, NEXT TIME I SEE
YOU...RUNWAY.
♪ ♪
>> HEY, GIRLS!
>> HI!
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS, RIGHT?
FINAL RUNWAY--THE FINAL CHANCE
TO SHOW THE JUDGES
YOU HAVE WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> WHEN I FIRST SEE THAT RUNWAY,
I'M SO TERRIFIED.
I'M LIKE, HOW AM I GONNA
WALK ON THAT?
YOU KNOW, IT DOESN'T LOOK FLAT.
>> TAKE A LOOK BEHIND YOU.
>> WORK IT, GIRL! WORK!
>> OH, MY GOD! MISS J.!
>> THE REAL EXCITING PART
IS THE THEME OF THIS SHOW--
EVOLUTION.
CARIDEE WILL BE LEADING OFF
THE SHOW.
AND YOU'RE GONNA START OFF
AS KIND OF LIKE "EARLY WOMAN."
>> WHICH MEANS THAT YOU'RE GONNA
PROBABLY COME OUT
A LITTLE MORE LIKE THIS...
AND AS THE SHOW GOES ON,
YOU JUST BECOME UPRIGHT.
>> AND MORE AND MORE
SOPHISTICATED.
>> THIS IS THE DUEL.
THIS IS THE FINAL.
♪ ♪
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S ACTUALLY
VERY DIFFICULT RUNWAY.
IT'S NOT JUST
TO BRING YOUR ENERGY,
BUT IT ALSO NOT TO FALL.
>> I'M NOT LETTING NATASHA
GET TO ME.
YOU JUST NEVER KNOW
WHAT STRATEGY SHE MIGHT HAVE.
♪ ♪
>> I'M VERY DIFFERENT
FROM JASLENE
BECAUSE SHE IS MORE FIERCE,
AND I'M MORE EXCITING AND FUN.
(snapping fingers)
>> THIS IS WHEN
YOUR NERVES ARE RUNNING HIGH,
BUT I'M EXCITED.
I'M READY TO GO OUT THERE
AND DO WHAT I DO BEST.
♪ ♪
>> (indistinct conversations)
>> (gasps) TYRA!
>> GIVE ME HUGS, GIRLS!
>> I LOVE YOU, TYRA!
>> OH!
>> YOU GUYS ARE THE FIRST WOMEN,
EVOLUTION. GO FOR IT, BUT NOT SO
MUCH
THAT YOU FALL APART AND LOSE
EVERYTHING.
>> REMEMBER WITH YOU,IT'S ABOUT
BEING STRONG AND NOT DRAG QUEEN.
AND WITH YOU,
IT'S ABOUT BEING STRONG
BUT NOT BEING STIFF.
ALL RIGHT, CAN I
HAVE A HIGH-FIVE?
>> YEAH!
>> (screaming)
>> ALL RIGHT, I'LL BE WAITING.
>> OKAY. BYE, TYRA!
>> BYE!
>> THIS IS IT.
THIS IS MY LAST TIME
TO SHOW THESE JUDGES
WHAT I'M MADE OUT OF.
>> THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING.
YOU HAVE A LOT IN STORE FOR YOU.
>> (cheering)
>> WE'RE GONNA START THE SHOW
RIGHT NOW.
>> OH, GOD.
>> POUND IT OUT! SERVE IT!
I WANT
SOME FIERCE AMAZON WOMEN.
>> OH, GOD.
THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE IS
ABOUT THE LAST RUNWAY SHOW.
>> I'M FEELING
THIS ADRENALINE RUSH
IS PUMPING THROUGH MY BODY.
MY NERVES ARE KICKING IN.
>> HAVE FUN, CARIDEE.
♪ ♪
(cheers and applause)
>> CARIDEE!
>> CARIDEE.
WHOO!
>> AM I GOING?
>> THE TWO OF YOU CAN GO.
REMEMBER, DYNAMIC!
♪ ♪
>> NATASHA IS WORKING IT.
>> I KNOW.
>> HURRY!
GET CHANGED. GET CHANGED.
(cheers and applause)
>> GIRLS, HURRY UP! HURRY UP!
>> GO.
♪ ♪
(cheers and applause)
>> I DIDN'T HEAR ANYTHING.
I WAS JUST FOCUSING ON MY WALK.
BUT MY SKIRT IS FALLING OFF.
>> SHE LOOKS GORGEOUS.
>> OH, MY GOD, SHE DOES.
>> WHOO!
>> HER DRESS IS COMING DOWN.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> IS SHE GONNA SAVE IT?
>> YEAH. SHE--SHE DID GOOD.
SHE DID GOOD, THOUGH.
>> I WAS ASHAMED,
BUT I NEVER SHOWED EMOTION
ON MY FACE.
>> YES.
>> AND... GO!
(cheers and applause)
♪ ♪
>> I'M ACTUALLY LOOKING
AT TYRA, NIGEL,
MISS J. AND TWIGGY,
AND IT'S LIKE,
OH, MY GOD.
IT FEELS SURREAL.
>> WE NEED THE BEGINNING
OF THE THIRD LOOK!
>> BACKSTAGE, IT WAS CRAZY.
>> OH, MY GOD.
NATASHA IS A WRECK.
>> HEY!
>> GIVE ME ANOTHER GIRL!
QUICK! QUICK! QUICK! QUICK!
WHOO! THIS IS CRAZY.
NATASHA!
>> NATASHA!
>> IS NATASHA READY?
OKAY, OKAY, JUST GO!
♪ ♪
>> I DID BETTER
THAN ANYBODY ELSE
ON THE RUNWAY.
I DON'T HAVE TO YELL AND SCREAM
THAT I'M THE BEST.
IF I'M CONFIDENT IN MYSELF,
EVERYBODY WILL KNOW IT.
>> I THINK I BRING FIERCENESS
ON THE RUNWAY.
AND I FEEL LIKE
WHEN NATASHA WALKS THE RUNWAY,
YOU DON'T FEEL THAT.
>> WHOO!
>> WORK IT OUT. YEAH.
>> ARE WE READY FOR A FINALE?
>> YEAH!
>> WHOO!
>> LOTS OF ENERGY!
(dance version of Tchaikovsky's
"1812 Overture: Finale" playing)
>> OKAY, GO, CARIDEE! GO!
(cheering)
♪ ♪
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> THAT WAS SO INSANE.
>> (laughs)
>> THAT WAS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE CRAZIEST SHOWS
I'VE HAD TO CALL EVER.
>> BECAUSE WE WERE THERE.
>> BECAUSE WE WERE IN IT.
(laughs)
>> YES.
>> (all screaming)
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> I HAD SO MUCH FUN!
>> YOU GUYS RIPPED IT!
Y'ALL WORKED IT OUT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MAMA'S PROUD.
>> THANK YOU!
>> BYE!
>> HASTA LUEGO!
>> BYE, TYRA.
>> BYE.
>> AAH!
>> THAT WAS SO MUCH FUN!
>> I DEFINITELY THINK THAT
I ROCKED IT ENOUGH TO WIN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
I AM AMERICAN.
MY FAMILY'S AMERICAN.
BY WINNING THIS COMPETITION,
I WILL BE A ROLE MODEL
FOR MILLIONS OF GIRLS
THAT FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE STRANGERS IN AMERICA.
I LOVED IT. MAYBE WE--
>> I LOVED IT, TOO.
I WANNA DO IT AGAIN.
>> I WANNA DO IT AGAIN! YEAH!
>> I'M THE LATIN SPICE HERE,
YOU KNOW?
LIKE, I BRING SOME EXTRA FLAVOR.
I'M THE EDGY GIRL.
I'M NOT YOUR GIRL NEXT DOOR,
BUT I'M YOUR GIRL NEXT--
DOWN THE BLOCK,
IN YOUR HOOD.
♪ ♪
>> WELCOME
TO THE FINAL JUDGING.
THIS IS THE JUDGING
THAT DECIDES WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ARE YOU NERVOUS?
>> (whispers) YES.
>> SO NERVOUS.
I'M READY TO PASS OUT. (laughs)
>> TODAY I'M NOT JUST SAYING
WHAT THESE PRIZES
ARE GOING TO BE.
ONE OF YOU IS GONNA BE
WALKING AWAY WITH THEM.
THE FIRST IS
A MODELING CONTRACT WITH ONE
OF THE TOP MODELING AGENCIES
IN THE WORLD,
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT...
A 6-PAGE SPREAD AND A COVER
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND WE HAVE JAY MANUEL HERE,
BECAUSE HE KNOWS YOU GUYS.
>> WE'VE HAD A LONG JOURNEY,
RIGHT, GIRLS?
>> YES.
>> YEAH.
>> NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND WE'RE GONNA START WITH
THE SASS & BIDE FASHION SHOW.
NATASHA, WE'RE GONNA
LOOK AT YOU FIRST.
WHEN YOU CAME OUT, UM,
AS THE ANIMALISTIC,
YOU KNOW, EARLY-WOMAN STUFF,
YOU WERE BEAUTIFUL.
YOU WOULD, LIKE,
LOOK TO THE LEFT, AND I WOULD
SEE THESE CHEEKBONES AND LIPS,
AND THEN YOU'D LOOK TO THE
RIGHT,
AND I WAS LIKE, WOW.
>> DID GREAT CONTROL,
CONFIDENT WALK.
>> WE KNOW BACKSTAGE,
WE WERE YANKING
THE DRESS OFF YOU.
YOUR HAIR WAS COMING OFF.
YOU INSTANTLY... (snaps)
PULLED IT TOGETHER
WHEN YOU WALKED OUT.
>> I NEVER KNEW THAT
ANYTHING CRAZY WAS GOING ON
WHEN I SAW YOU ON THAT RUNWAY.
>> SHE EVEN LOST HER SKIRT
ON THE RUNWAY
AND DEALT WITH IT AMAZ--
>> I ACTUALLY THOUGHT
IT WAS MEANT TO HAPPEN.
FOR ME, THOUGH,
IT WAS TOWARDS
THE END OF THE SHOW--
YOU LOST YOUR INITIAL POWER.
YOU'VE GOTTA KEEP THE INTENSITY.
YOU'VE GOTTA KEEP IT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH.
>> NEXT UP IS JASLENE.
>> YOUR LEGS--YOU SPREAD THEM
OUT REALLY, REALLY WIDE.
>> IT LOOKED LIKE
IN A JAMES BOND MOVIE,
AT THE BEGINNING,
WHEN YOU SEE SOME GIRL...
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> WHO'S, LIKE, GOING, LIKE,
DOING REALLY DRAMATIC
KIND OF STUFF.
IT LOOKED VERY BOND-ESQUE.
>> IT WAS COOL.
YOUR FIRST PASS
WAS A LITTLE, YOU KNOW...
>> EH...
>> SHOWY.
>> YEAH. EXACTLY.
>> IT WASN'T--IT WASN'T STRONG.
>> YOU'RE KIND OF GIVING ME
A LITTLE SIDE,
A LITTLE CHURCH FASHION SHOW,
LOOK INTO THE AUDIENCE.
>> A LITTLE... "HEY!"
>> COULD'VE BEEN A LOT STRONGER.
>> IT WASN'T... BAD.
IT JUST WASN'T AS STRONG AS THE
JASLENE WE KNOW.
>> AS YOUR PERFORMANCE
CONTINUED,
YOU BUILT THAT PERFORMANCE.
>> AND PART OF YOUR WALK
WAS AMAZING.
AND WHEN YOU GOT REALLY STRONG,
YOU CAN BE VERY POWERFUL.
YOU LOOK EXTRAORDINARY ON THE
CATWALK.
>> WHAT I LOVED ABOUT IT, TOO,
IS THAT YOU LOOKED LIKE
A WINNER,
LIKE YOU'VE ALREADY GOT IT
IN THE BAG.
NATASHA, YOU CAME OUT WITH IT
ORIGINALLY.
YOU LOST IT.
JASLENE, YOU DIDN'T START
WITH IT.
YOU ENDED WITH IT.
>> YOU GUYS HAVE HAD A LOT OF
PHOTO SHOOTS,
AND WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH
SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS.
YOUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU GUYS HAD TO SELL
VERY STRONG
POLITICAL STATEMENTS.
JASLENE WAS
FOR THE DEATH PENALTY,
AND NATASHA WAS PRO-CHOICE.
>> SHE BLENDED INTO THE BRICKS.
>> YES. I-I WAS SURPRISED
YOU MADE IT BEYOND THE SHOOT.
>> ALL RIGHT,
LET'S SEE JASLENE'S CLOSE.
>> I WAS BLOWN AWAY.
IT'S STILL ONE OF
MY FAVORITE PICTURES OF JASLENE.
>> AND NEXT WEEK WAS
YOUR HIGH SCHOOL STEREOTYPES.
>> I WANTED TO BE BEATEN UP
BY JASLENE...
>> (laughs)
>> AND I DIDN'T WANT
ANY OF NATASHA'S APPLES.
>> JASLENE,
THIS IS ONE OF THE BEST SHOTS
OF THE ENTIRE SEASON.
>> YOU JUST EXCELLED,
AND IT SHOWED YOUR VERSATILITY.
>> NATASHA, THIS WAS
THE MOST PAINFUL SHOOT FOR ME.
>> BUT WHAT WAS INTERESTING
ABOUT IT WAS THAT YOU--
YOU REALLY WERE TRYING HARD.
I THINK WHAT WE NOTICED IN YOU
IS THAT WILL
AND THAT DESIRE TO LEARN.
>> THANK YOU.
>> SO YOU DID
A GENDER-SWITCHING SHOOT
WHERE YOU ALL TURNED INTO BOYS.
>> I THINK BOTH OF THESE SHOTS
WERE GREAT.
NATASHA HAD THE ENTIRE ROOM
ON THE FLOOR,
ROLLING AROUND.
>> IT WAS YOUR IDEA
TO DO THE TOOTHPICK.
IT WAS YOUR IDEA TO PUT
GOLD FRONTS ON YOUR TEETH.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE WANT.
LET'S SEE JASLENE'S.
>> YOU DO LOOK LIKE A GUY.
IT'S AMAZING.
>> YOU ALSO HAD A DAY
WHERE YOU HAD TWO PHOTO SHOOTS.
ONE OF THE PHOTO SHOOTS
WAS FOR A MEN'S MAGAZINE,
AND THE OTHER PHOTO SHOOT
WAS FOR A WOMAN'S MAGAZINE.
SO LET'S SEE
YOUR BEST MEN'S MAGAZINE SHOT.
>> MY FAVORITE OF THE TWO
IS NATASHA'S.
I LOVE HER COMMITMENT
TO THE CAMERA.
>> AND MY FAVORITE ONE
IS JASLENE'S.
>> (laughs)
>> YES. I AGREE.
>> YOU'VE GOT THE EYE CONTACT.
IT LOOKS JUST RIGHT.
>> I WAS YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER
THAT WEEK
FOR THE WOMEN'S MAGAZINE.
JASLENE, I REMEMBER WHEN
YOU CAME ON SET THAT DAY,
I WAS SO EXCITED TO SHOOT YOU,
'CAUSE I THOUGHT YOU WERE
GONNA HAVE SOME PIZZAZZ,
AND WE WERE GONNA HAVE FUN.
AND--AND YOU JUST
KIND OF LIKE... BLAH.
YOU GOTTA ALWAYS
HAVE THAT JASLENE.
PEOPLE ARE GONNA BOOK YOU
JUST BECAUSE OF THAT.
>> I LOVE THE FACT THAT JASLENE
IS WEARING INVISIBLE "YIKES."
>> (laughs)
>> INVISIBLE STILETTOS.
>> FACIALLY,
THIS SHOT ON YOU, NATASHA--
I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT'S DYNAMITE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
YOU GUYS WOULD LIKE TO SAY
BEFORE WE HAVE THIS
VERY DIFFICULT DELIBERATION?
>> AH, WELL,
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT
I'M VERY THANKFUL FOR YOU GUYS
GIVING US A CHANCE
TO PROVE THAT WE CAN DO BETTER.
(speaking in Russian)
>> JASLENE?
>> IT HAS BEEN A LIFE-CHANGING
EXPERIENCE FOR ME,
AND YOU GUYS MADE ME FEEL
SO PROUD OF MYSELF.
GRACIAS POR ESTA OPORTUNIDAD.
>> ALL RIGHT. WELL,
IT'S THE BATTLE OF THE ACCENTS.
SO...
IT'S TIME FOR THE JUDGES
TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'LL ANNOUNCE
WHICH ONE OF YOU WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪ ♪
>> WE HAVE TWO BEAUTIFUL GIRLS,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
ONLY ONE OF THEM CAN BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> NATASHA IS JUST
ONE OF THE FUNNIEST PEOPLE
I'VE EVER MET.
>> I THINK NATASHA'S A GREAT
FACE.
>> NATASHA HAS GORGEOUS
FEATURES.
IT'S UNDENIABLE.
>> WHAT INTERESTS ME
WITH NATASHA IS HER ABILITY
TO BE A QUICK STUDY.
NO MATTER WHAT SHE HEARS,
SHE PICKS IT UP
AND SHE RUNS WITH IT,
AND I THINK NATASHA HAS A GREAT
FUTURE.
JASLENE STARTED QUITE STRONG,
FANTASTIC PICTURES,
BUT I THOUGHT THAT
JASLENE'S PICTURES
HAVEN'T REALLY IMPROVED.
>> THAT JUST MEANS JASLENE
STEPPED INTO THIS COMPETITION
JUST WITH A LITTLE MORE ABILITY.
I FEEL LIKE JASLENE'S JOURNEY
WAS COMING IN HERE ALL CRAZY.
LOOK WHEN WE FIRST MET HER
WITH YELLOW, PLASTIC EARRINGS,
SCREAMING.
AND LOOK AT
THIS SOPHISTICATED WOMAN
THAT WE SEE RIGHT NOW.
>> I HAVE TO SAY,
JASLENE'S PHOTOGRAPHS
HAVE BEEN SOME OF THE BEST
OF ALL THE GIRLS.
>> I THINK JASLENE IS
AN AMAZING EDITORIAL MODEL.
>> CAN SHE BE COMMERCIAL,
THOUGH?
>> I DON'T THINK
SHE'S A COMMERCIAL MODEL.
>> I-I THINK JASLENE
HAS THE ABILITY
TO BE A COMMERCIAL MODEL.
>> EVEN WITH THE CHIN?
>> EVEN WITH THE CHIN.
I THINK WHAT HAPPENS IS,
WHEN YOU HAVE A NEW MODEL,
THEY OFTEN CREATE A NEW LOOK.
THEY'LL BREAK THE MOLD.
>> THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
I LOVE BOTH OF THESE TWO GIRLS,
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT THE NORM.
>> THE PUBLIC MAY THINK WE'RE
NUTS,
BUT ACTUALLY,
IT'S THE IMPERFECTIONS
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
>> THEY'RE BOTH LOVELY GIRLS.
>> WHO DO YOU THINK
DID BETTER ON THE RUNWAY?
>> IT WAS A HANDS-DOWN FOR ME
THAT JASLENE DID BETTER ON THE
RUNWAY.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH.
>> AND I'M THINKING NATASHA
DID BETTER ON THE RUNWAY.
>> JASLENE BLEW ME AWAY.
>> I ACTUALLY THOUGHT THAT
NATASHA'S WALK WAS
A LOT STRONGER IN THE BEGINNING,
BUT I THINK HER WALK FIZZLED.
JASLENE GAVE A LITTLE MORE
SNAP, CRACKLE AND POP WITH HER
POSES.
>> I THINK
NATASHA WORKED THAT RUNWAY.
I LOVE 'EM BOTH.
WHAT THE HELL DO WE DO?
♪ ♪
>> THE TIME HAS COME.
THE JUDGES HAD
A VERY LONG DELIBERATION
BECAUSE BOTH OF YOU
ARE SO STRONG.
WHAT WE LOVE ABOUT BOTH OF YOU
IS THAT YOU BOTH COME
FROM SUCH STRONG CULTURES.
YOU ARE THE EPITOME OF WHAT
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
IS ALL ABOUT
AND WHAT BEING AN AMERICAN
IS ALL ABOUT.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT
YOU TWO GIRLS HAVE SOME OF
THE BIGGEST HEARTS AND SOULS
THAT I HAVE EVER SEEN
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
AND THAT'S WHY
IT MADE THIS DECISION
VERY, VERY HARD.
BUT WE FEEL ONE OF YOU IS
STRONGER.
WE FEEL LIKE ONE OF YOU
IS GOING TO BE NAMED
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
AND MAKE ALL OF US VERY PROUD.
IS...
>> JASLENE.
>> (exhales deeply)
OH, MY GOD.
TYRA, THANK YOU SO...
OH, MY GOD. (sobs)
>> (speaks indistinctly)
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU ARE SHAKING LIKE A LEAF.
>> (cries)
>> (laughs)
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
IT WAS SUCH AN EXPERIENCE.
I ENJOYED EVERY MINUTE OF IT,
AND NOW I'M JUST SO HAPPY
TO GO BACK TO--TO MY HOME
AND SEE MY FAMILY.
>> AAH!
>> TYRA, THANK YOU!
THIS IS THE BEST FEELING EVER!
EVERY LITTLE GIRL
HAS A DREAM TO BE SOMETHING.
MY FAMILY BELIEVED IN MY DREAM
JUST AS MUCH AS I DID.
AND TO BE HERE,
I OVERCAME SO MUCH.
I DIDN'T MAKE IT THE FIRST TIME,
BUT NOW LOOK AT ME.
I'M AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'M A COVERGIRL!
AND I THINK THAT SHOWS
TO ALL YOUNG WOMEN--
IF YOU HAVE THAT DRIVE,
KEEP GOING.
SECOND TIME AROUND,
AND I'M
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
HEY, LET'S SALSA. SALSA.
(humming)
YO GANé "TOP MODEL"
EN ESTE MOMENTO,
Y YO SOY UNA COVERGIRL.
OH, MY GOD!
I JUST WON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"!
YES!
(cheers and applause)
♪ ♪
>> STAY TUNED FOR A GLIMPSE
OF JASLENE'S FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
AS THE WINNER.
>> JASLENE'S THE REAL DEAL.
IT'S HER SPICY PERSONALITY
THAT REALLY SETS HER APART.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY,
JASLENE IS FIERCE.
♪ YOU WANNA BE ON TOP? ♪
♪ ♪
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP? ♪